[Musique]
est-ce qu'on continue comme ça avec
notre réseau de santé
et la réponse je pense que je la connais
c'est que c'est non et que le statu quo
n'est pas une option c'est un coup de
bar magistral que Christian Dubé veut
imposer au système de santé québécois
une réforme qui s'articule autour de la
création de l'agence santé Québec qui
s'occuperait de la gestion des
ressources humaines pour l'ensemble de
la province et dont l'objectif à terme
est d'améliorer le fonctionnement du
réseau le ministre veut aussi plus de
flexibilité du personnel des médecins
spécialistes de grandes ambitions qui
suscitent des questions et beaucoup de
grogne aussi peut-il réussir là où tant
d'autres avant lui ont échoué je pose la
question à Michel claire qui est
l'ex-président de la commission d'études
sur les services de santé et les
services sociaux c'est clair merci
d'être avec nous
bonjour monsieur Thibault bonjour ça me
fait plaisir peut-il réussir monsieur
Dubé pourquoi lui pourrait réussir là où
d'autres ont échoué ben écoutez moi je
suis un optimiste de perfectionniste et
analyse aussi à leur écouter la manche
je pense que le contexte est favorable
pourquoi parce que les Québécois les
Québécoises et dans l'ensemble des
Canadiens ce sont bien rendu compte là
des limites très importantes inhérentes
au système actuel donc je crois que les
esprits sont plus ouverts pour faire des
changements importants regardons
présentement là la situation qui a été
catastrophique pour les personnes âgées
pendant la pandémie bonjour à quel point
on est en retard dans le service à
domicile la prise en charge des
personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie
pourquoi parce que le ministère a été
avalé par des crises par de
l'exploitation par les opérations plutôt
que de la planification
pour que ça fonctionne monsieur claire
il faut il faut le concours des
syndicats des travailleurs on a déjà bon
monsieur monsieur duber on a parlé cette
semaine la semaine dernière
ça prend ça prend là des infirmières des
médecins spécialistes va-t-il réussir à
les avoir c'est là où ça bloque
d'habitude
regardez prenons la prenons la question
des médecins spécialistes moi je suis
très confiant il y a 22 ans nous
recommandions j'ai encore mon j'ai
encore mon rapport sous la main
commentation 27 et 29 nous faisions deux
recommandations à l'époque pour
accroître la responsabilité
populationnelle des médecins
spécialistes nous maintient de l'avant
d'abord l'idée de dire ce qu'on appelle
l'octroi des privilèges au médecin
spécialistes en milieu hospitalier mais
il y a pas une gouvernance clinique très
développée dans le milieu hospitalier au
Canada c'est les médecins spécialistes
puisque de dire comme ça mais il faut un
peu ce qu'ils veulent alors nous on
avait recommandé que l'ordre le 3D
privilèges le conseil d'administration
viennent préciser de manière assez
pointue les responsabilités les
obligations des médecins à l'égard des
services à la population mais en
contrepartie on nous avions également
proposé les médecins spécialistes libre
cours pour organiser des cliniques
médicales spécialisées affiliées un peu
comme en France
[Musique]
en France de
la chirurgie ambulatoire et faite dans
des cliniques privées conventionnés il y
a moyen de faire des choses équilibrées
qui vont donner plus de satisfaction au
travail mieux répartir leur
responsabilité en tous les médecins
spécialistes avoir une gouvernance qui
est plus transparente qui est plus
j'allais dire contemporaine et ma foi le
moindrement que de la bonne volonté des
deux parties je pense que c'est possible
est-ce que c'est possible avec les
infirmières parce que là vous me parlez
du code espèce des médecins spéciaux et
certainement remarqué que moi j'ai été
un peu surpris que le gouvernement aille
de l'avant avec l'idée d'avoir un
employeur unique et que
et que on invoque pour soutenir cette
que l'ancienneté en quelque sorte
favoriserait plus
davantage la liberté de mouvement soit
un territoire ma proposition à moi que
je vous dis je suis un optimiste
perfectionniste moi je me dis si nous
sommes pour avoir un employeur unique et
puis des gestionnaires au niveau local
au niveau des hôpitaux ont peut-être
même au niveau territorial mais moi je
pense que le moment est venu pour les
syndicats et pour le gouvernement
d'avoir des conseils d'établissement qui
viennent mesurer la satisfaction de la
clientèle mais aussi
satisfaction au travail de façon à
pouvoir éclairer l'employeur et les
syndicats sur des nouvelles façons de
concilier par exemple la compétence avec
l'ancienneté est-ce que ça veut dire de
vous de prévu à terme la fin des agences
privées
pour moi les agences privées écoutez je
m'excuse de le dire aussi crûment que ça
mais c'est l'enfant renié
du des employeurs et des syndicats parce
que en ayant des conventions collectives
trop rigides qui des gestions de
la gestion des ressources humaines trop
rigides mais qu'est-ce que ça fait ça
fait que pour les gens de mère ou père
de famille c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant d'aller en agence que de
travailler dans le réseau et puis le
fait aussi que si on veut développer la
compétence dis-moi j'aimerais mieux
passer d'un temps plein à deux je veux
continuer à me développer comme
infirmière professionnelle ou autre et
bien c'est pas favorisé le système de
favorise pas cela alors donc moi je
pense que si on veut éliminer les
agences là on est bien mieux du côté de
la médecine spécialisée multiplier des
beaucoup plus petit beaucoup plus
âgées et qui vont former les mêmes
conditions ou à peu près salariales pour
des infirmières avoir des cultures
organisationnelles qui sont plus
agréables les avoir aussi dans le réseau
de la santé vous savez la taille là avec
le salaire qu'est-ce qu'on achète on
achète des heures de travail avec une
bonne culture organisationnelle
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'on fait on
attache les coeurs au travail mais c'est
clair rapidement en terminant qu'est-ce
qui manque dans ce projet de loi là ou
quel est le plus grand défi de Monsieur
Dubé
je pense que le plus grand défi c'est de
convaincre les organisations des
syndicats de médecins et des autres
syndicats que la responsabilité ne
pourra améliorer le système mais
partager avec eux et je serais porté à
dire aussi que après avoir vécu son
qu'on a vécu je pense que tous les
partis politiques là ont un peu la
responsabilité d'essayer de trouver des
voies nouvelles pas juste de dire là on
veut encore plus de la même chose je
pense qu'il faut s'ouvrir à des voies
nouvelles puis c'est un grand défi de
convaincre tout le monde que chacun a sa
responsabilité dans l'évolution de la
situation pour le mieux on va suivre ça
avec beaucoup d'intérêts Michel claire
merci d'avoir été les nôtres cette
semaine ça m'a fait plaisir merci de
m'avoir invité